sri lanka's parliamentary speaker has
accepted the resignation of president
gotabaya rajapaksa sri lankans have been
celebrating after their embattled
president stepped down
for months they have been demanding the
removal of rajapaksa who they blame for
the country's severe economic crisis
he finally tendered his resignation
after fleeing to singapore
[Music]
on the streets of sri lanka people
celebrate after hearing the country's
president has resigned they say this is
a triumph for democracy
this is a huge victory we struggle here
more than three months and
i would like to say like it's this i
mean at this moment i feel is that good
lesson for all corrupted politicians in
sri lanka yeah it's extremely happy for
us because we were able to kick out our
president
who is the most powerful person in the
country uh we show the people powers
it's
extremely happy uh day for us
president gotabaya rajapaksa fled sri
lanka to the maldives ending up in
singapore before emailing his official
resignation
sri lanka has seen months of
anti-government protests with people
storming government buildings and taking
over heavily guarded compounds many are
frustrated with the worsening political
and economic crisis that's caused food
and fuel shortages
a day earlier protesters entered the
prime minister's office the man who they
worry will take over the country
some occupied the sitting areas
and others
took selfies
the army has been brought in to restore
law and order after prime minister ranil
vikramasingha now the acting president
called for a state of emergency
demonstrators have agreed to vacate the
occupied buildings but many say they
still don't have confidence in their
leaders
we have to continue our struggle
for the
future
while the president's resignation is a
start the protesters say they want a
complete overhaul of sri lanka's
leadership
they vow to continue to take to the
streets until they believe there is real
change
and dw's manira chowdhury is in colombo
for us so as we've heard there the the
speaker of the parliament has accepted
the president's resignation what happens
now
well yes this morning the speaker of the
parliament held a press conference where
he announced that gudeva rajapaksa's
resignation has now finally been
accepted and he has also announced now
if you talk about the next step the next
step is definitely the future course of
action a plan that the parliament has to
come with to stabilize the politics of
the country and for the same the speaker
did announce this morning that the
parliament will convene tomorrow and he
has requested all the mps all the
members of the parliament to come and
attend it to be present because the
future course of action is dependent
upon that so we can expect some
important crucial calls to be taken once
this parliament is convened
we're hearing that um meantime though on
the streets that are relative calm has
set in is that what you are also
observing
well yes uh the situation is relatively
calmer right now i'm at the moment
standing at the old parliament with
building which is right now the
presidential secretariat behind me you
can see a lot of people sitting calmly
on the staircase this entire area has
been the epicenter since the beginning
of the protests against rajapaksa in
fact the people renamed it as bota
gogama basically a place to demand his
resignation his ouster which has now
been done but the pulse of the ground is
that the protests will not abate anytime
soon their major demand one major demand
still remains which is for ranal vikrama
singha to step down from the post of
prime minister to step down from the
post of acting president now we don't
know whether that will happen that
remains to be seen but we can expect
protests to happen again
okay um tell us this latest move now
what does it mean economically for the
country because sri lanka is essentially
bankrupt and the previous government was
in talks with the imf for a bailout
well yes but one thing is really
important here to think about is that
economic stability will not come before
political stability does that is why the
all-party meeting of the government and
the parliament to convene is of utmost
importance in fact the governor of the
central bank of sri lanka even said that
the country may face a huge problem a
possible shutdown if a stable
administration is not brought into
position soon because even the imf
cannot roll out a bailout package since
that happens so that is of utmost
priority right now
dw's manira chowdhury reporting from
colombo in sri lanka thank you so much
so what does this all mean for sri lanka
i'm joined now to analyze the situation
by alan keenan he's from the
international crisis group in london
alan it's good to see you again it looks
like
the resignation will be confirmed
probably by tomorrow friday
what do you think comes next for sri
lanka
well it's certainly taken a while it was
a gotavia took us on a long wild goose
chase but um he seems to have landed in
singapore and seems to have agreed to
resign so that's good news i think
for sri lanka up to a point
what comes next well that's the question
it looks like rano vikrama singha comes
next he is now the acting president um
he will be sworn in
in a more official way tomorrow and he
will then have
30 days for his uh presidency to be
either challenged or confirmed through
through a parliamentary vote and i'm
hearing different things but it does
seem like
he is likely to be
voted in by parliament
so probably sometime next week
and
importantly with the support of the
rajapaksa's political vehicle the slpp
party
and that raises big questions about how
much
ranil will really be seen to be a change
uh from the roger boxes by the protest
movement and whether he can really prove
that he's something different and not
just
uh the agent of the roger boxes well
that also you know brings us to the
question alan is he going to get these
30 days to do anything are the
protesters going to turn the volume down
and let him stay in office for any
amount of time
yes well i think my hunch is there will
be a bit of a wane in the in the
energies of the protest uh movement uh
they're probably exhausted i mean it's
exhausting to be in sri lanka when you
have no fuel and not enough food and
high prices and but then to be spending
all your time in the street
demonstrating and fighting with the cops
and everything and taking over buildings
i think they're probably going to take a
little bit of a break but i do think
there's real potential here for for for
tension further down the line because
he's already i mean the demands the last
few months have been not just for
gotavia to resign but for ronald to
resign and for ronald to go from being
prime minister to actually being
elevated to president from the
protesters point of view that's that's
not good and more generally i think
ronnie vikramasinga is the
quintessential professional politician
in sri lanka and one of the targets of
the raj of the protest is not just the
rajapaksa family but the whole system
and raniel vikramasingha is not only
close to and has been protecting the
interests of the right of the roger
boxes but he is the essence of the
system that people want to change so i
think there's potential trouble coming
down the pike
and we know the country is in an
economic crisis the likes of which they
haven't seen in at least two three
generations this is a time when the imf
would usually be opening its door
willing to talk about a possible bailout
is an economic bailout is it even within
the realm of possibility when you have
so much political instability
yes well i think on that front my
reading is it uh well it all depends on
how tense things become again um if if
the tension levels if the protests can
be
uh sort of kept to uh to a reasonable
amount from the government's perspective
i think the imf is eager to help and
something needs to happen so i suspect
the imf deal will be formalized with if
ranel is made president um and assuming
anybody really becomes president who has
some credibility but um
but i think the imf package is not going
to come for quite a while the actual
money even in the best case scenario is
estimated to take six months and what's
going to happen in those six months
they're completely banked
that's a very good point time is
certainly not on the country's side that
is for sure alan keenan as always alan
we appreciate your time and your
insights tonight thank you
for some the political and economic
instability is already too much some
refugees have started trickling into
india from sri lanka according to save
the children two out of three sri lankan
families are struggling to find enough
to eat so those who can have started
arriving by boat across the narrow
strait that separates sri lanka and
india most landing on the island of
rameshwaram it's not far about 20
kilometers but it's the open ocean and
the crossings can be risky so far the
newcomers are mostly tamils the ethnic
minority group that fought a devastating
civil war in sri lanka for decades
they've come to india's tamil nadu state
a region that shares deep cultural and
linguistic ties
dw asia's critica narayanan is in
rameshwaram in the southern state of
tamil nadu critica what's the latest
what are you seeing and hearing down
there
i am standing in rameshwaram this is a
coastal town this is the southernmost
town of
of india this is the southernmost tip so
this is very near to sri lanka actually
so this is where for the past few months
due to the economic crisis in sri lanka
many sri lankan refugees are coming here
illegally through boats it takes about
three hours for them to cross over here
and they mostly travel by night and as
of now nearly hundred refugees have come
to this coastline they come to
dhanushkodi and archel munay these are
the points where they come and land and
they are being taken by enforcement
officials to the refugee camp in
mandabam where they're being held now
and
they have been coming for the past few
months steadily
yes
well i'm looking at
the sea behind you it looks pretty calm
right now but you mentioned night
journeys how dangerous is this um you
know boat trip and do you expect to see
more arrivals
it is very dangerous actually and in the
last week of june uh an elderly couple
tried to cross over there uh they're
very old and they tried to cross over
and one of the other elderly women she
died due to dehydration when she landed
on
she was unconscious then she landed on
the shore and she was taken immediately
to the hospital where she died uh
treatment plans stayed for her so uh so
it is dangerous for them but they do
take the risk to come here they sell
their land they sell their homes they
use that money and everything that they
have to rent those boats and they come
here they they they are uh so this is
not the first time refugees have been
coming to tamil nadu so tamil nadu uh
before in sri lanka during the civil war
a huge waves of refugees
did come here because tamil nadu they
are it's more culturally and
linguistically related to them they
speak the same language they they feel
like this is their home so they do keep
coming even though it is not a huge
number it's not a huge wave as it was
during the civil war it is a significant
number it's nearly 100 and they have
been steadily coming families have been
coming with children with children
little children carrying their children
in their arms elderly people like mostly
these people are coming from northern
and eastern provinces of sri lanka this
is where sri lankan tamils recite the
most this is this is uh so these sri
lankan tamils are the people who are
coming here as refugees and as the
this is not a huge wave it's not a
crisis as of now but if the economic
crisis in sri lanka is gets worse there
is the chance that more people could
come here soon
now you mentioned local officials being
involved how are they managing the
situation i mean it looks like in the
past this has been a route for refugees
are they treating the refugees well
india is not party to refugee
conventions so they are they are
treating these k refugee cases on a
humanitarian basis they are not party to
any law india does not also have any
domestic refugee laws to to handle these
refugees so these refugees are currently
housed in mandaba it's a refugee camp
there they are housed along with sri
lankan civil war refugees so they are
placed there and yes they are currently
there right now they are not allowed to
come out of there and uh because because
there is uncertainty because india is
not party to any international refugee
laws nor there is a regional uh domestic
refugee law for them and it's it's
unclear as to how we'll proceed from
there in the future will they be
repatriating them back to sri lanka that
remains to be seen
kritika narayanan thank you so much for
joining us
thank you
you